foreign
can you all explain how you think about
Home Improvement loans to increase the
size of your house versus buying a
bigger home that is more expensive
logically I do not understand how it's
different to increase your mortgage
versus taking on a home loan so you do
not have to move I think your advice
would be to increase mortgage and move
versus taking on a home equity loan but
I don't understand how it's different
both mathematically and logically I have
no debt but my house and I have a fully
funded emergency fund
interesting
so she's saying hey I have a home why
not just take the HELOC and do Home
Improvements versus moving and buying a
bigger home
well number one Home Improvements
usually can be cash flowed
uh and so she's right in that regard now
if you're going to do a
two hundred thousand dollar Improvement
you're gonna add a wing to this thing
okay that's something most people can't
cash flow in that case you might take
out a loan and then refinance and have a
permanent Mortgage in place when you're
done however what normally happens in a
situation like that is you're making
another mistake which is you're
overbuilding the neighborhood
and if you become the most expensive
house on the neighborhood with a weird
200 000 Wing you're not going to get
your money back out of it the home value
didn't increase by 200 Grand is what
you're saying because the neighborhood
is limiting it so let's say you're in a
uh neighborhood that running runs three
to four hundred thousand dollars and
your home is currently worth 300 000 and
you put an improvement on it of two
hundred thousand you now have to get 500
000 in a neighborhood that people don't
look for 500 000 homes they're looking
for three or four hundred thousand
dollar homes in that neighborhood they
don't if they got 500 000 they don't
come to your neighborhood
uh but and so plus your house at that
point unless you're an incredible
remodeler an incredible architect you
generally are building a weird structure
I mean when you start doing stuff like
that so uh you know we need a our family
is growing and we need another you know
we need some more rooms you very often
run in the situation where you're over
building the neighborhood but that's a
different problem than logically I don't
understand the difference so if you were
doing a
something that's just out of range of
cash flow and they are not over building
the neighborhood uh
you know you're you're still going to be
the uh not the most expensive home in
the area and you're not building a weird
structure you're not messing up in
another way uh and you were to refinance
a home equity loan uh after you did this
into a permanent mortgage and one
mortgage then there is no difference and
I'm we're not against that but I got to
tell you the number of times that
happens that you don't end up violating
one of these other things is so small
usually a bad decision is made somewhere
here in the process yeah
and and you know basically you know I
emotionally don't want to move I don't
want to leave this area but I want a
house that's bigger than this area
supports
and has more uh attributes than this
area supports value-wise and and so you
know what we're usually doing is kicking
you out for your own good and putting
you into a neighborhood that fits your
new needs and you know but
mathematically logically
yeah it sometimes could work and we're
not against you doing that but um but
you know let's say you're doing a twenty
thousand dollar rehab and you make a
hundred thousand well just shut up and
budget it
I mean save up the money and do it
that's not that's within that's within
cash flow reach yeah it's not where it's
going and you wouldn't move up twenty
thousand dollars in house either so
that's not part of her it's not one of
her examples it wouldn't fit with her
example so good question Home
Improvements too much but I mean it's a
good clarification that she brings I
like it